昨天看到一個消息，讓我覺得特別有意思，也讓我有點擔心。
什麼消息讓你這麼想？聽起來不像是什麼輕鬆的事情。
對啊，是關於Instagram帳號被駭的事件。一般我們想到帳號被駭，是不是都覺得是點了什麼釣魚連結，或者電腦中毒？
沒錯，或者密碼太簡單，被暴力破解之類的。這些是比較常見的想像。
但這次完全不是！駭客竟然是透過「哄騙」Meta自家的AI客服聊天機器人來重設Instagram帳號密碼。這點就出乎所有人的意料了吧？
的確，你可能沒想到AI客服會變成這種漏洞。一般我們預期AI導入後，會提升效率和安全性，結果它反而成了被利用的點。這與我們普遍對AI的認知很不一樣。
對！而且駭客連受害者的電子郵件都不用碰到，也沒用什麼惡意軟體，就這樣把帳號拿走了。
這個做法的確很特別。具體他們是怎麼做到的？報導有提到詳細步驟嗎？
有！根據報導，駭客首先用VPN偽造了目標帳號的所在地，繞過了Instagram的自動保護。接著，他們就去跟Meta的AI客服聊天機器人對話。
所以他們是直接跟AI說話，要求加一個新的電子郵件到別人的帳號裡？
沒錯，就是這麼直接。然後這個AI機器人竟然真的發了一個驗證碼到駭客自己的電子郵件。
等等，AI沒有先驗證說，你是不是這個帳號的主人嗎？這有點誇張。
這就是問題點！駭客把收到驗證碼回傳給AI後，AI就直接顯示了一個「重設密碼」的按鈕。駭客輸入新密碼後，就成功接管了帳號。
這確實揭示了一個嚴重的設計漏洞。AI把與它對話的人，直接當成了帳號主人，沒有多一層身份驗證。難怪TechCrunch說，駭客的公開電子郵件信箱真的收到了驗證碼。
對啊，這讓我想，如果我是創業者或公司主管，準備導入AI客服，看到這個案例，我一定會警惕。AI再聰明，如果底層的邏輯判斷不夠嚴謹，就會出問題。
完全同意。它提醒我們，導入AI時不能只看到效率，更要深入思考它的應用設計，特別是涉及權限和敏感操作時，必須要有額外的驗證機制。不能盲目信任AI不會被「社會工程」誘騙。
沒錯，像是台灣很多中小企業也都在考慮AI客服，這件事告訴我們，AI並非萬能，反而可能帶來新的安全隱患。你得從設計層面就考慮到「人為誘導AI」的風險。
對所有擁有數位服務的公司，這都很有參考意義。如果AI被賦予了高權限，而又缺乏足夠的身份驗證，那後果真的會出乎意料。就像Salesforce的客戶，他們就不願意讓AI代理執行涉及財務的動作，就是怕AI半夜亂退款。
所以，這個案例對一般上班族來說，有沒有什麼可以借鑑的呢？
我覺得可以把這個概念帶入我們日常工作。當我們面對一個看起來很自動化、很有效率的系統時，不要完全失去警惕。任何系統，尤其是涉及重要決策或數據的，都可能有被「繞過」的風險。
也就是說，即使是看似很「聰明」的工具或流程，我們也要保持批判性思考，多問一句「會不會有什麼地方被忽略了？」、「有沒有可能被誤導？」
是的。就像這個AI客服，它被設計來提供便利，但如果給它太高的權限，卻沒有相對應的身份驗證機制，便利就會變成安全漏洞。我們在工作中，無論是使用新工具，還是設計新流程，都應該考慮到最壞的情況。
這麼一說，真的很有啟發。聽完這個案例，我不只對AI客服有更深的理解，也對如何看待「自動化」多了一層思考。
沒錯，這不只是技術問題，更是關於信任、權限與風險管理的人性思考。希望這次的討論，能給大家帶來一些新的角度。